yeah who uh okay so I want to give you
flowers here because
I think if we're looking at the bay area
right there's 40 and Too Short
those are like okay 42 short then
there's Mac Dre
then I'd say there's like G-Eazy um
but I feel like after a guy like gee I
mean obviously there's like to keep the
sneaks and the jackers of the world and
and uh hot shout out to Jairo uh I know
Hyrule day just happened but I kind of
feel like consistency you're kind of
like knocking on [ __ ] what eight nine
years straight you've really been like
representing the city at a super high
level I feel like you're really kind of
starting to like catapult yourself in
like the conversation of being like all
time
[ __ ] from the city man man oh I mean
that's an honor we're from the area
right yeah from the area I mean that's
an honor you know I mean like I think
that was you know when I want to set out
um uh the journey because I knew it was
going to be a journey and it's still the
journey and that's just from my
perspective because I know like big Von
and uh Dame will watch this and have a
[ __ ] absolute [ __ ] convulsion but
just from from someone who's not from
the bay yeah you know
yeah of course yeah it is Legends they
put together their top Bay Area listen
I'm just like what the [ __ ] but again
I'm not from there so yeah yeah no I
mean dude like just just just the base
is such a legendary spot for like rap
and music and the in culture culture in
general and just to be just for me to be
able like like
for you to be like a in that
conversation you know what I'm saying
because you you might not even be 100
right or one and day might not be 100
right but just to be in that
conversation with those with those names
the people that are like oh like I grew
up too and people that I like look up to
um man that's
that's love man because I think of it
like this I'm like okay probably the
most important movement out of the bay
the last 10 years is 100 hpk gang and
you've 100 I mean shout out to keilani
in terms of hip-hop you've been the most
relevant and successful person in HBK
gang to come from it rather and to me
like HBK gang is like a moment in time
yeah that like was like crazy like when
you guys would do those yearly concerts
and all that [ __ ] but the fact that like
you were able to like take that and
never stop and just keep going up up you
know what I mean I mean I mean I I think
that just goes back to like I mean
during those days man we were out we
were around a lot of great people like I
mean Sue is like like yeah architect
like like I'm nowhere where I'm at
without Sue
cool John like you know what I'm saying
that movie almost [ __ ] crazy that was
that's I but that's I think that's that
album really like I feel like that's
when things change for you okay yeah no
one thousand percent like um because I
remember you had was it art was it RB
what's the one where you had the baby
with a little uh more business more gold
chains yeah that was the uh
what was the song in there I used to
play in the club going to work yeah
going on to work yeah it was hard but I
feel like at that time you were kind of
like the little homie yeah no no like
you were like yeah we love his Beats
like he also raps a little like yeah no
for 1000
um but yeah like I mean without those
guys like I don't like
I'm nowhere in that conversation for
sure you know what I'm saying those
those people helped me so much and those
people helped guide me those people gave
me the confidence to even do what I'm
doing you know what I'm saying Sage Sue
cool John all those guys like those are
the people that are like I I continue to
look up to you know what I'm saying just
and as humans and in life so it's like
um just to be in that is like yeah
HBK is like incredible yeah fire